no one can imagine anybody else playing
that role but you so what were you doing
what's your secret come on I love the
whole concept of scientists who deal
with insoluble problems I love the story
of noted scientist who was trying to
find the solution to some problem and
just did in the comedy work on for
months and then one day he's not
thinking about anything he's getting on
the bus and it comes to him you know and
Doc Brown is trying to figure out how
did how to do a time travel and he falls
down on the bathroom and hits his head
against the sink and he suddenly
envisions the flux capacitor you know so
I love that kind of connection because
it's kind of the way it works well so
it's just that's basically the eureka
effect yeah get hit in the head or
something happens too abruptly and then
the idea pops in but I'm a fan of the
way Isaac Asimov interprets the eureka
effect which is which is go ahead okay
you ready the most exciting phrase to
hear in science the one that heralds the
most discoveries okay is not Eureka but
rather that's funny that well that makes
sense yeah so meet you do you agree with
this yes I had exactly that moment I
first was working on string theory in
the 1960s and it consisted of hundreds
of random formulas that he had to
memorize in a book but Einstein wanted
an equation one inch long that would
allow him to quote read the mind of God
so I said to myself hmm that's funny
how come this theory has so many random
equations there should be this one each
equation one day I found it it's called
string field theory that's my equation
I'm the co-founder of string field
theory and it summarizes a theory beyond
Einstein in one inch long
but was that a Eureka moment or did you
just sort of it was a that funny moment
that it that no one was looking for and
no one was looking for this one inch
equation right because people were so
busy memorizing and using all these
little hundreds of little formulas that
they would memorize no one was looking
for that one is equation